hello everyone and welcome back to the
second day of the world rapid
championship this is round six and uh we
have four players on four and a half out
of five Magnus Carlson Vladimir fedosi
and Jordan van Forrest here who is
magnus's opponent for this game and they
have played extremely well and they uh
almost had a perfect score but we have
no one on perfect score after day one so
now we'll see who emerges on top after
day two so this is the sixth round uh we
are covering Magnus versus the Jordan
fan Forest uh always a very exciting
matchup as Jordan has helped helped the
Magnus prepare in the past he was his
second and he knows quite a lot about
magnus's preparation as he was uh
himself invested in preparing Magnus for
his matches uh so uh it's a very tricky
matchup for Magnus as well so it's very
interesting what he will choose
yesterday he had uh two times he played
B3 with the white pieces and uh we'll
see if he continues doing that today but
as it turns out no he doesn't in this uh
they do he opened with the English
opening he plays C4 and well this is
already where the fun starts with E6 by
Jordan G3 D5 and now Bishop to G2 and
here almost exclusively Knight to F6 is
played but Jordan plays D4 this is the
sixth most popular continuation so he
really wants to try and get Magnus out
of his preparation as soon as possible
uh D3 and now Pawn to C5 now cementing
that pawn on D4 magnets of course will
challenge it with E3 Knight to F6 and
now there is a game last year it was
played in the American Cup elimination
around between level and Ray Robson
where F4 was played Levon was able to
win that game but here we have e
captures and D4 by Magnus and it is not
as of move 6 that we have a completely
new game see calculus on D4 Jordan
recapters and A3 now Magnus wants to
throw in a nice B4 and Jordan stops that
of course with Bishop to G5 Knight the
CC 6 and now Knight the D2 the Knight
will be able to come to E4 at some point
Bishop to E7 and not Knight to E2 uh
both players Castle so castles castles
and now Pawn to E5 by Jordan and here
Magnus says all right it's time to grab
that E4 Square let's eliminate the
Knight so Magnus gives up the bishop
pair characters captures and now goes
Rook to E1 uh in 94 immediately although
it's a great Square for the Knight is
easily countered by Bishop p7 and then
F5 will dislodge the Knight black gets a
very nice attack going so instead just
rookie one by Magnus he will put
pressure on that E5 pawn and Jordan
starts with H5 the bishop pair is very
strong here he wants to play H4 maybe
even H3
so C5 by Magnus grabbing more space here
and also saying that he would like to
place a knight on C4 and then maybe D6
or even B6 if Jordan allows it so Bishop
back the seven Jordan goes after the
pawn and Rook to C1 Magnus defends it
and now uh you should definitely
consider defending the five pawn
something like Rook to E8 or queen to C7
uh goes a long way but Jordan played
Bishop to E6 sorry not right away at
first he played A4 and even Bishop T6
would have been okay but A4 gives Magnus
too much time and it's hard to say if
Jordan I I don't think he blundered upon
I think he just uh wanted to enjoy the
full benefits of the bishop pair so
that's why he gave it up and the Magnus
says all right Knight the C4 and now you
you have to play Bishop G5 this is the
the the last time to do so or Rook d8
but Jordan now goes for Bishop to E6 and
here Magnus will just grab a pawn bishop
captures on C6 uh B captures and Knight
captures on E5 and okay Jordan still has
the bishop pair but how does he make
them fully operational he goes Bishop to
G5 attacks the rook and C1 but Magnus
throws in a nice Knight to C6 attacks
the queen also Knight to F4 can be
considered but this is rapid chest so
Knight captures on C6 attacks the queen
queen F6 and now Magnus just plays F4 uh
defends his rook and what has Jordan
gained here he plays Bishop to B3 okay
the queen is attacked Queen to D2 and
now Queen captures on C6 we have F
captress on G5 and now Queen to D5 so
Magnus does have a beautiful pass C Pawn
but his King side is a bit shattered now
if Jordan could place his light Square
Bishop let's say here and put pressure
along this diagonal that would be
excellent
uh so Queen D5 attacks the pawn on G5 uh
Magnus further cemented with H4 now the
queen doesn't have to uh defend it Rook
8 the C8 now attacking the pawn and just
Knight to F4 uh attacking the queen with
Queen to D7 and now Rook to E4 uh
putting pressure on this opponent D4
also just a very nice uh Rook lift and
Magnus had some eight minutes here on
the clock Jordan had some three minutes
and the Magnus could go for the H5 Pawn
but instead he goes Queen to F2 uh sorry
Rook to C6 uh at first the block hitting
the pawn and also the The Rook will be
very nice here guarding the sixth Rank
and now while Magnus could go for the H5
Pawn he first goes Queen to F2 he puts
pressure on the D4 Pawn not in any rush
to to win that pawn Rook the d8 Jordan
defends it and now Knight captures an H5
and here you can see that Magnus is up
quite a lot of Pawns uh if you counted
that seven pawns the four uh Bishop to
D5 now attacks The Rook so Jordan is now
successful in placing the bishop on this
diagonal but will he be able to employ
the deadly Bishop Queen combo so here
Rook captures on D4 now the bishop
cannot move with Queen to C8 and now
Knight the F4 attacks the bishop once
again Rook captures on C5 Jordan wins
that that pass Pawn but now Magnus just
trades down into a winning end game Rook
captures on C5 Queen captures Knight
captures and D5 Rook captures on D5 you
know if this was a classical game okay
Rook character as an A4 is definitely an
idea it looks dangerous here because
your king is wide in the open but even
if Queen C1 check King to H2 there's no
good way for black to do anything if you
if you go for the pawn go for something
like Queen to D2 it's a very easy
Checkmate King H2 Queen F5 check and
that's it G6 uh Queen captures and F7
Checkmate so after Rook captures on D5
okay Jordan uh
uh Magnus captures md5 Jordan captress
on D5 and now just Pawn to D4 and now uh
usually when you have a queen and Pawn
in game if one side is up by one Pawn uh
then okay you you have drawing chances
even sometimes when it's two pawns but
here uh it is three pawns and this uh
will be very very hard to draw we have
Queen to E4 and Magnus goes Queen to D2
he is now ready to start pushing his
pawn queen to F3 Jordan wants to grab
the G3 pawn and just King H2 so now with
the with this Pawn defended with the
queen controlling the second Rank and
with the queen ready to uh escort the
Deep one of the board uh not much to be
done here Jordan blockades it but now
just Queen to D1 Magnus also goes for
the A4 pawn queen to B5 and now Magnus
while he could just continue pushing and
give up the B2 pawn and this is
perfectly fine uh just in case you are
wondering let the queen captures King H3
and now how do you stop the pass spawn
let's say queen E5 you go D6 Queen to E6
check you just go back and after Queen
to D7 uh this is uh well just a terrible
Square for the queen uh at some point
Magnus will play H5 H6 create another
pass pawn and uh sort of a principle of
two weaknesses will prevail so instead
Magnus goes Queen to D2 he doesn't want
to give Jordan any control play and he
first wants to set up the other pass
Pawn on the king side Queen to D5 with
H5 now and queen to F3 going after the
H5 Pawn but just H6 the queen also helps
out with this diagonal Queen to H5 check
King to G2 and queen to G4 and now
Magnus just continues Pawn to D5 uh both
players have around three minutes here
so it's not like anyone's in any time
trouble uh Quinta E4 check and now just
King the H2 and it was in this position
animal 42 that eurom farm Forest
resigned in the game as there is nothing
uh more to be done here so in this game
the student did not surpass the master
and uh well Magnus gotained fairly
fairly clean win now it's hard to say if
that was a pawn sacrificed by Jordan or
did he just blunder upon I don't think
he blundered I think he just thought
that the bishop Queen combo would be uh
sufficient uh compensation as they tend
to be very active but just in this game
they weren't so if you wonder how this
might go if you're if you're new to
chess let's say captures captures now
Magnus would have two best pawns and
there's not all that much you can do
here you can try to stop the pawn with
the King let's say D6 King 38 even D7
check into it but now the other pass
Pawn is a problem let's say queen F4 uh
any Queen trade is always winning for a
while because white is up too much
material let's say queen to C2 checking
H3 Queen to G6 but now just King the H4
now threatening Queen G5 check the the
trade of the queens and after Queen H7
G4 and so on there's really no move you
can make here uh with uh with black even
if King captures on D7 you can just
trade Queen F5 check captors captures
and of course the end game is still
completely winning for for white so
that's a problem when white is up two
material up to too much material in a
queen and pawn end game he can just
trade queens and uh when you have that
option that makes it all the uh all the
more uh simpler to achieve this uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it Magnus is now on five and a
half uh out of six so uh definitely
having a good start usually Magnus uh
will will mess up somewhere during the
first day but here he just uh continues
crushing opponents uh we'll see what
happens in the next round and I know I'm
I'm following magnus's games for this uh
Championship uh I know you guys would
enjoy it more of them but as he's doing
well he is the world champion and he uh
well he's just crushing everyone uh I I
always enjoy uh watching that myself so
hope you guys do too as well uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank Ben Edwards Lars
Oliver Grand Hava Jeff Graves David Rice
Oxley and Kevin Clark for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on what's
happening in the video World rapid
Championship until it finishes uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day